[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So today, we've changed
it up a little bit
and met here at
Schlesinger Library.
We discussed a packet of poetry
a prolific female authors
who are based in
Cambridge and in Harvard.
And we were able to see a
lot of original documents
from Adrienne Rich's
life at the library.
- One of the ways we understand
the work of any great writer,
if we are so lucky as to have
access to that writer's papers,
is to watch the writer develop
through the kinds of materials
that are not available
to the public.
- So we got to kind of
go through the timeline
of her life, looking
at the things
that she left behind
and left to Harvard.
I got to see things that she
drew as, like, a six-year-old.
- She had one very
impressive poem on cavemen
where she had a very
opinionated view
on how modern men are lesser
than cavemen from that time,
which I found hilarious.
- And then kind of move as she
became this college student
at Radcliffe, as
she started to delve
into, like, feminist writing.
- For instance, to have the
correspondence in one's hands
that Adrienne Rich exchanged
with all the major poets
of her moment is to
understand something
you can't get from just
reading an individual poem.
- This side of poetry
that you don't always see,
getting to see how these people
were real, they interacted.
- It's to understand the
conditions of publication
that bore on the poet, a
sense of poetic community.
- So in a normal
seminar room, I think
it's more like we
read the poems,
we say, oh, this poem
has a definite structure.
This lends to
emphasize this point.
But you can't really see
how a person changes just
by reading their work.
You can really gain
more if you look
at their personal
artifacts and get
to see, like, their journals
from when they were a kid.
- It made me feel a
lot closer to the works
that we were talking about.
It feels like you're kind of
right in the epicenter of where
it was created and
where it came from.
You kind of came back to
the home of Adrienne Rich.
- It was just amazing, from
an academic standpoint,
to be able to see the person
that we're reading about
and see their physical
evidence of their life here.
- There's always going
to be something new
here for me to find, and
for me to learn about.
- The resources here
are absolutely amazing.
Being able to just simply ask to
have a look at some of Adrienne
Rich's or various other famous
poets' and authors' works
whenever you want is a resource
that I don't think many people
are afforded.
- I brought them
to the Schlesinger
because I wanted to
expose them to an archive
where one can touch
materials, some of which
have never really been
interpreted before.
And so the exciting
originary work of a scholar
is something that one can
begin to give students
a sense of by bringing
them to an archive.